what would a conversation look like with
zero
questions this is a bit of an odd
question that crossed my desk
but i have a really fun answer that has
transformed the way that i
dive in and engage in conversation with
people both in
personal life and also with my uh wife
and also uh in work relationships in a
work context
and it's really interesting not that i
recommend
diving into a conversation and asking no
questions at all in fact
uh me and will wrote a book about how to
ask questions in order to create
conversations that really matter
and yet if you completely remove
questions from your conversational
vocabulary
in this video i'm going to share four
levels of listening
that create the opportunity to have a
really fantastic conversation
even though you haven't asked
necessarily if you stick around the
video i'm also going to share
15 phrases that are really really
phenomenal phrases
that create better conversation better
listening these are phrases that can be
perfectly fitted to whatever context
and content of the conversation that
you're in
and they're really really useful as
reflective listening phrases so in a
world where you couldn't ask any
questions
or for some reason you just were aware
of how many questions you were asking it
started to feel a bit like an
interrogation these 15 phrases
are really really useful to pull out of
your back pocket
to ensure that somebody feels heard and
the conversation continues
forward with a little bit of momentum
i'm chad
happy to be in cyber space with you
today let's get into it
[Music]
when i'm watching a video i love to know
kind of the path of where we're going
before we get strung along too much so
the four levels of listening
are verbatim translation
unstated feelings and connecting the
dots
let's take each one of those and expand
them a little bit
at the end of this video you will 100
percent be
a better listener if for some reason you
feel cheated by this video
and you don't feel like a better
listener and a better conversationalist
at the end of this video
you can write me an angry email find my
email somewhere and me and will will
send you a free copy
of ask powerful questions create
conversations that matter
all right you've got to prove to us
though that you learn nothing in this
video
so verbatim reflection so first of all
all four of these levels of listening
are really levels of reflective
listening
and reflective listening is the idea
that if i were to hold up a mirror
to your words or whatever you're saying
to me
i'm just going to hold up and reflect
them back to you now there's lots of
ways that you can reflect if you've ever
been into a
fun house at a circus or something
there's the mirror that's kind of curved
that makes you look really long there's
one that makes you look really wide
and then there's just a normal mirror
point is you can reflect in lots of
different ways
first way is verbatim reflection
so so the first way is verbatim
reflection
do you see what i just did there just
literally repeated exactly what i just
said
verbatim word for word and that is the
idea of
verbatim reflection now this sounds
ridiculous and when i first learned it
um it felt ridiculous to do but i
was shocked i still am shocked that when
i verbatim reflect what i heard somebody
else say
how frequently they either say oh that's
exactly what i mean
or they're like no no no no no this is
what i meant and then they actually
clarify
it's it's phenomenal like literally just
feeding somebody's words back and i
think it's
partially because we're in our own heads
and as we're speaking we don't hear
exactly what we sound like
when we're speaking necessarily and so
that verbatim reflection is a really
easy way to reflect back keep a
conversation
uh going forward now i will say verbatim
reflection is probably most likely to
end a conversation if the person's like
yeah that's exactly what i got
and so if your goal is to have a
conversation with no qu by asking no
questions
that might be a tough one second one is
translation
so that is where i take most of your
words
edit them a little bit and then
repeat them back right i might take your
language and
put it into my language so there are two
types of translation you can do a simple
translation
and a far out translation simple
just making some slight tweaks so that
it doesn't sound like i just parroted
back
exactly what you said far out
translation is where i'm using my
own words as the listener and expanding
on meaning
so if you tell me if i ask you how was
your day
and you tell me it was really good i had
a big win at work and family life is
good
i could say simple translation wow it
sounds like you had a
really good day at work and things are
going really smoothly with your family
right just a simple translation nothing
too crazy
now if you said that same thing a far
out translation might look like
wow it sounds like your life as a whole
is going really really well
do you see how that was my own words and
i even expanded on the meaning of what
you just said in that in that moment now
the power of a far out translation
is when you expand that meaning you
often
invite a really thoughtful response from
the other person
either clarifying or expanding on what
you've just said
because you've taken some liberties and
gone extended the conversation extended
what they said a little bit further
than what they actually said harder to
do but extremely powerful if done well
the third level of reflective listening
is reflecting back
unstated feelings and this is a
really useful one that is extremely
underutilized
and what i mean by that is when we speak
words come out of our mouth
and most of the time depending on who it
is most of the time they're not
necessarily filled with
emotional words they're not you know
people don't necessarily say i'm really
sad right now
or i'm really angry right now sometimes
we do but more often than not
we're describing something that's really
making us really frustrated
but we don't say i'm angry just we see
that frustration
and so reflecting back unstated feelings
would be
something along the lines of just
looking back at them and observing
hey i can see that you're really
frustrated right now in fact my wife and
i
are uh reading this parenting book
together
and i love the there was a comic in it
that showed a kid who bumped his head
and was crying screaming
really reacting and the parent was just
uh there was two types of parents one
was and the most common thing that we do
with people's feelings
is deny and dismiss them you see
somebody's feeling really sad you're
like no no it's okay
it'll be good like this is only
temporary blah blah blah
right so you kind of dismiss and deny
but the idea here
was to unpack a little bit further to
talk with the kid to get them to share
and unpack why it is that they're
sad and to acknowledge to get them to
realize that sometimes they're not sad
because especially when a kid is really
really sad that is all they can think
about right they're so absorbed
in that world whereas if you're able to
pull out
and you have some unstated feelings
reflected back at you
it gives you some more awareness and
some more choice over your emotions
which is an extremely powerful gift
to give to somebody and then the fourth
level of reflective listening
is really really cool connecting the
dots this is where you get to take
people and connect them to ideas and
connect people to people and ideas to
ideas
in the way that you actually listen and
feedback and so i used to work for an
organization called world and
conversation and my job was to sit down
with a group of strangers and talk about
really soft fluffy topics like
race relations long term conflict
politics religion
etc with no agenda other than to
understand the other
and one of the neatest things that would
happen in those conversations
maybe about 60 minutes into the
conversation
is there would be so much conversational
data so much story so much
experience out on the table that people
were sharing that there were just so
many
dots that could be connected in that
conversation in fact i was in
one conversation a dialogue with a
kid who was black grew up going to a 98
black school
in new york city and a kid who grew up
in rural north carolina
where i may not have seen somebody who
was black especially
at school and now they're sitting in the
same room in a conversation with being
facilitated by me about race relations
and at the end of the conversation they
looked at each other and said
dude you are just like me
it was such a powerful moment um because
and what sparked that was they actually
connected the dots themselves
i can't take any credit for that aha or
that bridge building
and what essentially brought that up was
at one point
somebody was sharing that their parents
told them when they went out of the
house
to watch out for white people
and to be mindful of the way you were
acting around white people
and somebody else's parents said when
you walk into the house
be mindful of how you interact around or
with
people who are black in that
conversation right they saw
and they actually they saw these dots
being connected they actually looked at
each other and said dude you're just
like me
and that's the power of really great
connecting the dot type of listening
is as the facilitator or as a leader or
as an educator
to be able to connect what somebody's
talking about now
with what they did talk about the in the
past or what somebody else talked about
in the past
or to connect two people in the present
just having the language of thinking
about listening to connect the dots
will make you a really really fun
conversationalist to be around
so now that you've got four levels of
reflective listening it's helpful to
have
phrases that mix up the way that
reflective listening sounds because you
don't want to sound like dr phil that
just says i hear you saying i hear you
saying i hear you saying
right repeat back because when you're
reflective listening too much you can
start to sound like a therapist or a
counselor
which likely if you're watching this
video is not your goal
or your aim and so here are a bunch of
different phrases from
page 138 in ask powerful questions
that you can use to start reflective
listening statements now
my editors are going to just fill up the
screen with them so that you can pause
and screenshot them if you want
my invitation before i read them off and
share them with you
my invitation is for you to pick out two
or three
that are not your normal vocabulary of
listening
and add them to your back pocket because
when you're able to mix it up even just
between two or three you don't need 15
phrases necessarily
but pick two or three that feel like you
that you'd feel comfortable using in
conversation
and just have them in your back pocket
it's a really great way to
keep a conversation meaningfully going
without questions and also to make
somebody feel
heard right in the same way that a
mirror makes somebody feel
seen reflective listening makes somebody
feel heard
so you might be able to say so you are
wondering
you believe so you're thinking about
i hear you saying so what you are saying
is you seem i'm getting
you think it is important to you it
feels like you are
what i'm understanding is it sounds to
me
like you sound as if you are
sounds like from your perspective it
seems
as though okay i don't actually know if
that was 15 or not
um but here's a handful of phrases if
you want more you can download a free
excerpt of this online
uh if you enjoyed this video you also
love these ones it was awesome hanging
out in cyberspace with you i'm chad
littlefield
have an awesome day